I’m gonna be honest with you guys, I’ve
been putting this video off for almost a
year now. Revisiting the worst of Game of
Thrones is always a painful experience to
go through and after making my almost
half-hour-long breakdown of season 8,
I was broken and drained and did not want to
go back to talking about these episodes. But
this video is inevitable, If I made a top 10
best episodes video then I have to do the flip
side. So get ready to feast on my misery as we
dive into the worst episodes of Game of Thrones.
Number 10 - Season 6, Episode 1: The Red Woman.
This might be a bit surprising to some people
that season 6 is leaking onto this list, but
after revisiting this episode during my season
6 devoid of logic videos, I relived how bad this
episode was. Almost every scene here has a glaring
writing issue that doesn’t make any sense. From
the whole situation with Ser Alliser allowing
someone to take Jon’s body and then getting mad
about it, along with him openly admitting that he
killed Jon. Sansa and Theon conveniently getting
saved by Brienne when she was busy with Stannis.
The power grab in Dorne is extremely inconsistent
since Ellaria Sand was literally just detained by
guards for a potential coup and now they’re A
OK with killing Doran. The Sand Snakes being on
the ship with Jaime, Myrcella, and Trystane and
for some reason they let Jaime go despite them
killing Trystane. The Sons of the Harpy being
able to burn Dany’s entire fleet without anyone
noticing. The Dothraki going out of their way to
capture Dany when they didn’t know who she was.
Jesus Christ the writing tanks so hard in this
episode and I’m surprised that we were so blind to
this when it first came out. Like there’s really
nothing to be enjoyed here and even the dialogue
is at an all-time low. I was considering putting
an episode from the beginning of season 7 here,
but at least there’s a scene or two that are
at least entertaining within those episodes.
Then The Red Woman ends in the most scaringly
disgusting way possible in which Melissandre
takes off her necklace and we see her
shriveled-up ballsack of a corpse. Did
we really need to see this? Not to mention that
this is also inconsistent with past scenes in
which she didn’t have her necklace on and she
didn’t turn into the old lady from Spongebob.
This is a prime early example of David and Dan
struggling to write an episode from scratch.
Number 9 - Season 5, Episode 6: Unbowed, Unbent,
Unbroken. Despite the terrible scenes that
transpire within this episode that we’ll talk
about in a second, 25% of this episode is made
up of thoroughly engaging scenes of Arya doing
chores. This is a point where I’m sure this whole
development is way better in the books because you
can have Arya’s internal monologue and extensive
thought process while in the House of Black and
White. But in the show, you obviously can’t do
that and she doesn’t have another character for
her to talk to and express what she’s thinking.
That’s why to me, this whole development with her
here is so boring. Along with Jaquen seemingly
jumping the gun and immediately showing Arya the
great hall with all the faces. Even though she is
still failing her tests. So that’s a big chunk
of the episode that most people will probably
skip altogether. The crazy thing is that the
episode gets progressively worse as it goes on.
Like we then go to Tyrion and Ser Jorah getting
captured by pirates and they consider chopping
off Tyrion’s cock. Which is just such a jarringly
weird dialogue scene and when you compare this to
Tyrion outsmarting the mountain tribe it’s such
a massive difference in quality. In one scene
you have Tyrion taking advantage of the low IQ of
his captors and promising them riches, along with
defusing all the tension with his well-executed
humor. In the other, Tyrion just says that he has
a big cock. So yeahhhh. And also do cock merchants
even exist? Then Littlefinger scheming is baffling
and has no semblance of coherency since he gave
Sansa to the Boltons and now he wants to become
warden of the North by attacking the boltons.
And apart of this plan between him and Cersei
is he’ll kill Sansa, so right away this scene is
pointless because we know that won’t happen. David
and Dan were just like oh, we have a bare minimum
requirement to make it seem as if Littlefinger is
still smart and is scheming. The episode keeps
spiraling with the terrible climax of the Dorne
plotline and any action here is poorly executed
with tons of cutting. It also doesn’t make sense
how these soldiers choose not to turn when
they do so a few episodes later in season 6;
how convenient for Jaime who’s infiltrating Dorne.
The final scene of the episode is probably one of
the most abhorrent moments in the show in
which Ramsay rapes Sansa. We really didn’t
need to see this and felt more like David and Dan
injecting shock value to try and increase ratings.
Number 8 - Season 7, Episode 5: Eastwatch. Oh boy,
I love opening an episode by getting smacked in
the face with a big schlong of plot armor. Bronn
must be an Olympic free diver if he was able to
swim Jaime while he was in full armor across
an entire lake. It’s very clear that David and
Dan wrote themselves into a corner by including
Jaime and Bronn in this battle and needed some
way for them to escape. And they didn’t even try
to make it make sense. Then Dickon randomly just
kills himself and I feel like David and Dan were
probably thinking “I don’t know what to do with
this character, let’s just kill him screw it”. And
then they try to play this off as Daenerys being
unreasonable, like ok. One of the main reasons
why I’m including this episode within my list
is because of how absurdly fast each character
was able to travel around Westeros. Just in this
episode alone, we go from this general area to
Dragonstone, from Dragonstone to Kingslanding,
from Kingslanding back to Dragonstone, and then
from Dragonstone all the way to the goddamn wall.
This destroys any semblance of space within this
world because it destroys all logic in how long
it would take to travel to these locations.
The main way to make it seem natural would
be to have in-between scenes or even episodes
to pad out that time, but David and Dan gave
up and cranked up the pace. It’s also funny to
me how Dany returns to Dragonstone on Drogon,
but somehow the Dothraki made it back before
her because these people were present during the
Loot Train attack. The other big reason why this
episode is here is because of Tyrion’s brilliant
plan to kidnap a wight to convince Cersei to
help them. I don’t think I need to dive into
why this mashed potatoes logic is coming out
of young Sheldon, because obviously it would
get everyone killed and Cersei would gladly let
the dead kill the north because that would be her
best chances of winning at this point. From this
point on, it’s basically as if the dragon crew
is assembling the avengers as they zip around the
globe and it is even served up with marvel quips
like Davos quoting the meme of Gendry endlessly
rowing. Before this, season 7 was mediocre and
kind of bad but this episode self-mutilated
the potential of any redemption for the rest
of the season from how horrendous the direction
David and Dan decided to take the story here.
While also fully and utterly compromising
Tyrion who was once my favorite character.
Number 7 - Season 8, Episode 1: Winterfell.
This episode doesn’t have a lot of atrociously
insulting scenes that make you want to light your
eyes on fire and then extinguish them in acid,
but the general writing is still coated in trash
and is apparent by this point that David and
Dan stopped trying. Hell, the first line of the
season is Tyrion making a cock joke. Scenes that
you’d think should have nothing wrong with them,
still are being fumbled. Arya and Jon’s reunion is
laughably short and lazily written, Kingslanding
is completely barren and since it’s just Cersei
and Euron, David and Dan have no idea what they
should talk about other than sex and elephants
oddly, Bronn is given an objective to kill Tyrion
and Jaime despite Cersei not actually wanting
that so it puts his character in limbo the whole
season as he goes to the Bahamas for a vacation,
Theon just waltz into Euron’s fleet with zero
conflict and saves Yara, rendering that whole
plot point as anticlimactic, Jon and Daenyers
riding dragons is shockingly reduced to sitcom
satire when it should have been a triumphant
reveal, and Tormund and Edd conveniently run
into each other despite it being illogical.
It feels like anyone could have reviewed this
script and addressed these issues, but the only
thing I can think of is David and Dan not caring.
Even some of the biggest moments feel dampened
by the poor dialogue. During the grand reveal of
Jon Snow being Aegon Targaryen he just resorts to
the copy and pasted dialogue that he repeats for
the entire season. Not to mention that the scene
ends in less than a minute after Sam tells Jon
the big news. If David and Dan weren’t rushing
through these scenes as fast as possible then
they could have easily written 10 episodes worth.
This is kind of a larger issue within seasons 7
and 8 but it’s more noticeable for the episodes
that are primarily composed of dialogue scenes.
How am I supposed to form any attachment to these
scenes when you are quickly ending them with very
little resolution and proper development. It feels
like we are just going down a checklist of plot
points to set up before getting to the big action
set-pieces. Instead of having any semblance of
being like the earlier seasons where each dialogue
scene was fully explored and engaged the audience
with its riveting and complex characters.
Just thinking about the notion of Sansa and
Jon having a scene together arguing makes me
sick to my stomach at this point in the story.
Number 6 - Season 7, Episode 7: The Dragon and
the Wolf. The last 20 minutes of this episode
ranges from alright to good, but the first hour
is an absolutely miserable experience. We have a
forty-minute sequence of our now brain-dead
characters trying to have an intellectual
discussion. Starting off this forty-minute-long
nightmare, we have Bronn talking about unsullied
who don’t have cocks. Ah yes, I sure do love the
topics that David and Dan decide to explore in
their dialogue scenes. Then for the actual general
reunion, it never has any substance. From the
blatant cleganebowl unskippable ad, Euron randomly
chiming in to make jokes, and Jon giving his Night
King speech for the one-hundredth time, this is
just terrible. For the amount of characters here,
it’s really sad that David and Dan weren’t able
to come up with a single memorable or even decent
interaction. This also isn’t even mentioning
how this entire sequence has no point in the
overall story. Why is Cersei even entertaining
the notion that she cares about helping? What
are Jon and Dany going to do about her not
helping, kill her harder? Like what’s the
point of Cersei bamboozling everyone here that
she’s going to help? It literally serves no
purpose and is just a waste of time. If you were
to remove this scene and went right into season 8,
almost nothing changes. The only key difference
is Jaime’s involvement, but you can still easily
write in a way for him to get upset and to help
the living. If anything, I’d prefer an arc where
Jaime realizes how evil Cersei is and that aspect
slowly drives him away and he switches sides. Not
because she lied. Given that Jaime’s overall arc
is basically the opposite of Cersei’s in that he’s
becoming more honorable and morally good, while
Cersei is becoming more wicked and is pushed
further into that abyss through each death of her
kids. You’d think that the death of Tommen would
have a bigger impact within their relationship
because Cersei was partially responsible,
but that whole aspect goes unexplored. Or even
just acknowledging the fact that she blew up the
sept. The Kingslanding narrative in this season
was so barebones already that this more developed
dynamic between Cersei and Jaime was much needed.
Although Jaime’s arc works here in this episode,
I think it could have been done better. So
taking out the factor of Jaime, It feels
like this entire sequence is to only justify
the reunion of Cersei and Tyrion so that David
and Dan can try and utterly fail at re-living the
best of Game of Thrones’ past. And the sad thing
is that it worked. The critics ate that shit up
and the season received a bunch of awards. Then
there’s one other crippling issue in this episode
and that’s the death of Littlefinger. Saying that
David and Dan committed a character assassination
would be kind because this man has been done so
dirty since the beginning of season 5. The more
you think about anything Littlefinger does,
the less it makes sense. And then to make
things even worse Bran just farts around
and doesn’t bother with telling anyone that
Littlefinger is a menace to society. David and
Dan yet again create a false sense of tension
because it’s completely illogical for Bran to
withhold this critical information. This finale is
a massive waste of time and it also comes with a
side of David and Dan plunging a dagger into our
hearts for how they handled a beloved character.
Number 5 - Season 7, Episode 6: Beyond the Wall.
This was the original point in the show that
shattered my illusion that Game of Thrones
was still a good show. Because before this,
the flaws were there, but they were somewhat
ignorable because they didn’t go absolutely
ape-shit in terms of terrible writing. The
inherent goal that David and Dan created where
Jon and company have to go beyond the wall to
steal a wight is singlehandedly one of the most
stupid directions to take the story. I still don’t
know why they couldn’t have had Dany at least fly
them in and out for this mission instead of what
transpired. Or even Dany flying in to scoop up
some wights in Drogon’s claws and bring them back
south. The fact that you can immediately with
very little thought come up with a better plan
than the smartest character in the show is very
telling for how horrendous the whole episode is.
Then the execution of the episode writing-wise is
even worse. The wights that end up chasing Jon’s
entourage end up getting stopped because the ice
broke, even though they have been shown to be
able to swim. Gendry, a man who grew up in the
warm climate of Kingslanding, is able to somehow
run miles nonstop back to the wall without his
lungs exploding in this extremely cold weather.
You’d think Tormund would be more suited for that
objective given that he grew up in this terrain.
Jon’s entourage constantly surviving certain death
scenarios, Jon for whatever reason not wanting
to get on Drogon because he was getting carried
away killing wights, and then Jon miraculously
surviving and having Uncle Benjen come in like
the eagles from Lord of the Rings to save him.
Did we need to have this moment for Uncle Benjen?
Then this is padded out with the dumb conflict
of if Arya is going to kill Sansa. And Sansa
is again listening to Littlefinger, someone who
she really should not be trusting by this point.
Almost every aspect of this episode sucks ass and
there may be a few moments in the beginning with
some interesting dialogue, but it’s jarring to
constantly use cock jokes in almost every episode.
Number 4 - Season 8, Episode 4: The
Last of the Starks. Oh boy here we go.
Between the last four episodes of season 8,
I hate this one the least because it doesn’t
absolutely butcher a major aspect that the show
has been building towards. But don’t get me wrong,
The Last of the Starks is still horrible. This
episode includes the single most jarring point
in the entire show which is the death of Rhaegal.
The fact that David and Dan play this scene to
surprise the audience as random shock value is
the most degenerate form of writing. A good twist
should be logical within the story at the very
least and should have a small thread of buildup.
Like the Red Wedding and the death of Ned Stark.
Here, it feels like David and Dan are in panic
mode as they have no idea how to match those highs
from the earlier seasons. What’s that? We were
literally just reminded about Euron’s fleet the
scene prior? Oh, shouldn’t we send scouting ships
ahead so that we stop getting ambushed by Euron’s
fleet which ALREADY HAPPENED TWICE IN THE STORY!
You’d think that they would learn from their
mistakes, but David and Dan throw out all logic in
the story to bend and break it at their own will.
This time to the complete detriment of one of
Dany’s dragons that the audience has come to love
through the years. And this is just one scene in
the episode. The vast majority of the celebration
plays like a sitcom because David and Dan find it
easier to write quote-on-quote comedy rather than
Drama. Along with it including this classic line,
“I don’t really want any more”. Which perfectly
sets up the ending in which he wants to become
the king. “Why do you think I came all this
way.” The romance between Jaime and Brienne felt
really awkward to me, Jon is stuck in his never
ending loop of saying muh queen and I dun wan et,
Bronn randomly comes in out of nowhere to then
exit the story again, and Missendei somehow gets
captured by Euron with a dash of coughing varys.
I am leaving out one scene that upsets me more
than these which is Jon telling Arya and Sansa
his true identity. This again highlights David
and Dan’s utter laziness in writing because they
don’t even bother to show us critical reactions of
his closest family members. Like this should be
the best scene of the episode and David and Dan
somehow fumble the easiest touchdown in existence.
Then the final scene is so bizarre where Dany’s
support group shows up to Cersei’s doorstep
to beg them to surrender. This essentially
resembles the finale of season 7 where everyone
knows the outcome of this scene and it ends up
being pointless. But the reason why this moment
is worse is because Cersei has the means to end
the war right now. She has multiple scorpions
pointing at a motionless Drogon and could easily
barrage Dany’s whole group with arrows. Or they
could literally just open the gates to reveal the
golden company that then slaughters them. Cersei
doesn’t have Jaime’s good moral conscious to hold
her back and I’m surprised Euron didn’t encourage
her to slaughter them all here. But yet again,
this is another contrived scenario so Tyrion
could give an emmy baiting monologue to Cersei.
Number 3 - Season 8, Episode 3: The Long
Night. If I were to go back and remake my
devoid of logic videos for season 8, I’d find the
most material within this episode from how crazily
brainless it all is. So lets go through a quick
laundry list of everything I can think of that’s
stupid in this episode. Jon and Dany waiting an
unnecessarily long time to do strafe runs on the
army of the dead, the Dothraki randomly charging
the enemy despite being told not to, the layout
of the army by having the trebuchets in front
of your soldiers and not digging more trenches,
our frontline of heroes miraculously surviving
a literal wave of undead that washed over them,
our non-fighting heroes hiding in a crypt that
famously has corpses in them, not creating a
failsafe mechanic to light the trench on fire if a
dragon becomes incappacited, not having any siege
like materials like pouring oil on the dead, and
Jon being able to keep fighting after crashing
on Rhaegal and being A OK along with being
surrounded by wights and surviving. Also not
to exaggerate but almost every instance in which
our characters are fighting the undead, they are
put into scenarios where they should have died.
I think everyone was surrounded at some point and
the wights decide to hug them instead of instantly
stabbing them like they did to the extras. Let
alone Sam the Slayer wrestling the undead in the
mud. You can’t go a few minutes in The Long Night
without being visually assaulted by the abysmal
writing and having plot armor permeate in every
single moment. What a great way to destroy any
form of tension when everyone is immortal now.
This was once a show where a character died from
an infection. Then that isn’t even bringing into
light or should I say darkness the fact that you
can’t see anything. I get that this battle takes
place at night but any example of night shoots for
battles has tangible lighting in them and you can
always use the moon as a general light source.
Also despite this entire episode being an action
set piece, there was only a couple choreographed
extended fight scenes like Arya fighting up on the
wall. Besides that, all the action is just quick
shots of people randomly swinging at wights and
that quickly gets repetitive. So since we covered
all that shite, we can now finally talk about the
ending. The fact that David and Dan are basing the
entirety of this moment on subverting expectations
instead of a proper moment of payoff that has
been built up to for years is mind-boggling.
It’s very clear that David and Dan didn’t know
what to do with Arya later in the season so they
probably panicked and gave her the Night King.
Even though her killing the Night King doesn’t
actually utilize any of the skills she acquired
because she literally just rushes in for the kill,
or fly I should say. This episode manages to
completely squander the single biggest aspect of
the show that so many people were hyped to see and
was the major moment where the casuals realized
how bad the show was. Because up until this point,
the show was still getting good reviews on IMDB.
Number 2 - Season 8, Episode 5: The Bells. This
episode is like having the foresight that a train
is about to crash and you are powerless to stop
it and you have to witness it in slow motion. I’m
sure this episode wouldn’t be absolutely terrible
if David and Dan bothered to do some real writing
and develop these characters and have them make
realistic decisions based in logic. With real
seasons composed of 10 episodes that don’t
just rush through the plot points in an any
percent speedrun, then I’m sure this moment in
the story would make sense. But the fact that
Dany wins the war with essentially no losses
and then decides to snap for no good reason
is baffling. It creates an immediate disconnect
with her character because the writers are forcing
her to do something that isn’t properly set
up and are only filling in a plot point that
George RR. Martin told them that happens. Then
we are left to sit here and witness this shit
for the remainder of the episode. It’s really
hard to enjoy this spectacle when it doesn’t
feel earned in any way. That’s why I can’t give
it any redeeming qualities. Not to mention that
there are still dumb aspects like the scorpions
suddenly not working. Like in every wide shot
that shows the scorpions, they are always
motionless and seem like they aren’t manned.
Which is a massive difference from the episode
before, that had Rhaegal get head shotted from
miles away while moving. And of course, all this
is accompanied by other disgustingly incompetent
writing choices like Jaime saying he doesn’t care
for the innocents which broke his character arc,
Euron coincidentally swimming to shore at
the exact spot and time Jaime is there,
Arya suddenly transforming into a cat because she
now has nine lives, and Jaime and Cersei dying to
a bunch of bricks. When literally any other
fan theory that predicts the fate of Cersei
and Jaime is better than what you were able
to come up with, then you know that you are
horrible writers. Every now and then you’d find
maybe one of these egregious writing mistakes
in the last couple of seasons like Arya getting
stabbed multiple times and living in season 6,
but here, writing mistakes of that caliber
happen are in every other scene. The only thing
here that is half entertaining is clegane bowl
but even that feels like fan service in a way.
I feel really bad for the actual production
side of things because it’s a complete waste
of talent in having all of these amazing effects
and huge sets bring to life an atrocious script.
Number 1 - Season 8, Episode 6: The Iron Throne.
By this point in season 8 I was inconsolable. I
sat there like a lifeless husk as I witnessed
my favorite show succumb to some of the worst
writing I’ve ever witnessed. So does it get
better from here? “Absolutely fucking not.”
Not only does this episode have a plethora of
god-awful moments, it’s also overly drawn out
with filler. We have to watch every character
slowly walk through Kingslanding as if this
is some deeply moving material and Tyrion moves
chairs around like an ADHD maniac. David and Dan
are in full crisis mode as HBO and the audience
expects them to output episodes over an hour long,
so they just give you drool-inducing scenes that
don’t engage the audience in any way. Like what
was the point of this scene where Greyworm was
executing soldiers and clearly was so far gone
that he didn’t care anymore. Shouldn’t this be
setting up a showdown of sorts between Greyworm
and Jon after Jon kills Dany? Since Greyworm
clearly wouldn’t let Jon live for doing that.
It seems like this scene was on the cutting room
floor because David and Dan didn’t even bother
with the notion of Greyworm teleporting to the
entrance of the Red Keep when Jon was walking
there the whole time. Then I’m sure the death of
Daenerys would have been enjoyable at this point,
but the audience is so emotionally detached from
the insane roller coaster of dreadful writing
that this scene comes across as soulless. Oh hey,
Drogon are you here to give Jon some consequences
for killing your mother? Oh, you’re not, well
ok then. This leads into what I’d consider the
worst scene in the show which is the election of
the new king. Everyone knows what’s wrong here,
but it’s still hilarious to me that David and
Dan try to pass off stories making a good king
as if it’s some kind of big and smart revelation.
When it just comes across as absurdly stupid. Then
somehow David and Dan keep face-planting with
the writing in regards to the Iron Islands not
wanting independence, Greyworm allowing Tyrion
to give a monologue, Bran actually wanting it,
the scene including the now sadly normal flare
of sitcom comedy, and an incompressibly worse
method of electing a king. Do you realize how
much more corrupt this process will be if it’s
an election process between the elites? You
will have to deal with intimidation, bribery,
and flat-out assassination attempts in order to
gain votes to become king. This system is so much
worse to the point that it’s disrespectful to
Dany’s memory. Even though she wanted to break
the wheel by essentially making an even bigger
wheel I guess, so I don’t know. The Iron Throne
is an excruciating ending to season 8 and now
they want to continue the story from here with
Jon. I wish the best of luck to those writers
because you have a colossal obstacle ahead of you.
Those are my top 10 worst episodes of
Game of Thrones. I hope you enjoyed
going down this cursed and appalling
memory lane of sorts. But yeah,
thank you for watching and let me know
what your top 10 worst episodes are.